probleme etwa dann wenn volksentscheide
die menschenrechte beschneiden
volksentscheide wie dieser gegen die
masseneinwanderung
provozieren proteste
und die svp macht laufend weiter druck
um ihre agenda durchzusetzen
ich darf hier und jetzt bekannt geben
dass wir nach nur fünf monaten
1982 unterschriften überreichen die
offenen die schweizerische volkspartei
svp will das parlament zwingen ihre
sogenannte ausschaffungs-initiative
kompromisslos umzusetzen
jeder ausländer der in unserem land eine
straftat begeht soll nach verbüßen
seiner strafe automatisch ausgeschafft
werden
eine forderung die regisseur thomas
issler empörte
umso mehr als das ja dazu applaus von
der falschen seite bekam
gesprächen filmemacher über
rechtspopulisten europa wird die akte
demokratie in der schweiz als vorbild
gesehen und in der warmen recherche und
entwicklung von einem film hat sich lage
in der schweiz weiter zugespitzt man
rufe jetzt viele meter fokus in der
schweiz
einziger unterschied
der film ist nun so etwas wie ein
lehrstück über die direkte demokratie in
der schweiz
die kampfjets stürzten letztlich an der
urne ab das schweizer stimmvolk legte
aber auch ein jahr ein zum verbot von
minaretten und es beschloss die
unbedingte ausschaffung krimineller
ausländer
obwohl damit die menschenrechte verletzt
werden
im herzen der konservativen schweiz will
man nichts davon hören
svp volkstribun christoph blocher
punktet hier mit hohn und spott
gegenüber dem staat
aber jetzt meine er holte gegen 10 uhr
volksrechte
wanderte h schaffen und originell war
der welt um gott wir haben volksrechte
daran in der st volkssouveränität
bedeutet dass es das volk ist wo will
immer ca und das ist der richtige
begriff
zu landes bestimmt aber sony tor
verwehrt und
zollikofen
menschen wohl zu dem volk current
benachteiligung und diskriminierung
sturzes volk selber diskriminieren
wer ist das volk
als ich geboren wurde durfte meine
mutter weder wählen noch abstimmen
das stimmvolk war nur halb so groß wie
heute psychisch krank dass ich einen
film auch wenn ihm eine träne bringen
will ich glaube dann thema direkte
demokratie dann hoch politische thema
kommen nicht
einen film machen wo sozusagen wenn sie
das gibt es gar nicht oder falsch ist so
genannte ameise fielen bis wir das volk
und sie in einfache mehrheit der plural
es gibt kein hauptverfahren darin der
debatte sondern sich mit dem gesetz
verhalten verschiedenste stimme und
den blickwinkel so block
demokratie ist ein balance akt
kontrollieren und ausgleich
die macht richtig verteilen
deshalb gibt es die gewaltenteilung
die regierung der gesetzgeber die
gerichte
man hält sich gegenseitig in schach
jedem seine aufgabe
das bedeutet nichts anderes als dass das
volk nicht immer das letzte wort haben
kann der film stellt die entscheidenden
fragen
soll das parlament vorstöße die der
verfassung widersprechen gar nicht erst
dem volk vorlegen braucht es ein
verfassungsgericht dass diese prüft
der regisseur liefert keine antworten
aber er outet sich am ende als fan der
direkten demokratie
aller menge zum trotz ich bin politische
wurde glaube alles vorhat vor die stimme
größer wird sehen das ist eine
politische frage ist das ist doch in
trance gut dass der nacht gut und die
macht folk die glaube ich momentan der
demokratie stelle immer wieder
die direkte demokratie gibt uns die
größtmögliche freiheit zu bestimmen wie
wir leben wollen
eine freiheit mitspielen
egal wer gerade gewinnt oder verliert